[Music]  mr miracle the great escape is all about  scot-free but scot-free shown in a  different way he's a student at the  goodness academy on apocalypse and he  longs to escape apocalypse is a place  without hope there's a place ruled on  fear  there's hell  and then there's the goodness again you  know daniel did a great job of paying  homage to kirby's original art you know  that kirby crackle that we see sometimes  in the fourth world stories but also  pushing it in a new direction in this  really cool afrofuturistic way seeing  some of his action scenes especially oh  just great just just mind-blowing lots  of heist some action a little bit of  romance all bundled in jack kirby's  fourth world  you